hey everyone welcome to simply launch
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about excel budget template
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn
now without further ado let's get
started with our one point agenda that
is how to create an excel budget
template
for that let's get back to practical
mode where we have to start our
microsoft excel and see how to implement
excel budget template
so on my screen you can see an example
excel budget template theme
so on my screen you can see a column
where you have the debit amount
so in the i column we have all the
amount what we are spending for a month
and on the right column will be the
balance amount or the running balance of
that for example you can see that there
is a row number five where the debit
amount is eight thousand for a change
levis and it is done through upi payment
now if i change this value of 8000 to
4000 something
then you can see that these running
balance will automatically change you
can see that currently the running
balance is 73 000 and if i change this
value from 8000 to 4000 then all the
running balances will change
let's do that so for that let's press
enter
there you go you can see that the number
has been changed successfully and all
the values from the running balance are
also changed until the last day which is
the march 30th
now how is this working and not just
that you can see that we have also
included what is the total debit amount
in january and what is the running
balance that is the total available
balance
after one lakh has been debited into the
account in the month of february as
february income
now the current available balance is 1
lakh 13 200 and the total expense in
february is 1 lakh 4 500 right how am i
doing all this looks so much interesting
right now let's do this practically
so for that i have already created a new
sheet and i have included all the data
that we have used previously
the income of that particular month and
all the expenses of that particular
month
now without further ado let's begin to
implement the excel budget template now
our first step happens to be converting
all the data into a natural table so you
know that in excel all the data values
are stored in the form of a database by
default so it happens to be our duty to
convert the database type table into the
pure table type table so for that select
all your data and press ctrl t and there
you have an option to convert this data
into a table
and remember to check this particular
checkbox
and tell your excel that your table has
headers
so we do have headers here so now press
ok
and your table will be converted into a
natural table
now let's type in the formulas
so now let's select the cell j2
and type in the formula
so what are we doing here is we are
trying to
add the sum of j2 plus h3
so which is this particular cell and
removing i3 that is this particular
debit amount so this formula is used for
checking the running balance
let's press enter and there you go
so it means that you received
one lakh rupees in the month of january
and out of that one lakh you spend
fifteen thousand rupees for something
maybe your educational or something and
then the remaining running balance out
of one lakh rupees is 85 000 rupees now
let's copy the same formula to all these
cells
and there you go
now the running balance has been
calculated for all the cells here
now remember the monthly income
available balance and debit for january
and final balance now let's try to
calculate that for all the three months
so here we have three months that is
january february and march
now let's do a simple calculation to
find out the available balance of that
month and the total debit made by that
person in that particular month
the formula is really simple all you
have to do is use a sum function and
calculate the sum of all these values
and done right
there you go so the total expense of the
month january is 93 800 rupees
now let's calculate the total debit of
february month same formula that is
calculating the sum of
all the expenses made in the month of
february
day
now let's also calculate the
sum of all the expenses in the month of
march
done
so we have the final values of all the
total expenses made in those particular
months
now
let's calculate the final balance
now i think i forgot one important thing
so before we calculate the final balance
we need to find out the available values
that is the available balance after
one lakh rupees is created into our
account and along with the savings that
you have from your previous month right
so that we have a simple formula
now which all we are doing is just
adding the
income
sell with the balance cell that's all
so there you go
now after crediting one lakh rupees and
adding up the
balance of that particular month that is
we have 13 200 remaining from the month
of january and the month of february we
have income of one lakh so the total
amount is 11 300 and
no no it is
1 lakh 13 200. yeah
now we have the final balance that is
the difference between the available
balance and
the debit made in that particular month
so in the month of february we had a
total balance of one lakh thirteen
thousand two hundred and the total debit
of one lakh four thousand five hundred
so the final remaining values as eight
thousand seven hundred
similarly the same formula has been
applied for the month of march and the
final balance we have is 37 300 so
that's how you implement budget template
in excel all simple formulas and you
have all the numbers at your fingertips
so with that we have come to an end of
this tutorial on excel budget template
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries until next time thank you
stacey and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here